on episode 7 of potatoes a hundred
different ways I'm making this soft
Savory and cheesy potato mochi
so easy to put together to make things
easy I'm using idahoan's buttery home
style mashed potatoes just mix the
boiling water and let it stand for one
minute for delicious mashed potatoes
usually these make the perfect quick
side dish but today I am transforming
them into the main dish by adding potato
starch to the idahoan mashed potatoes to
make Mochi place a cube of cheese in the
center wrap the dough around and shape
into a Patty cook the patties in a
skillet with oil over medium heat until
golden brown next make the Yaki sauce by
combining liquid ingredients and brown
sugar then simmer the sauce until it's
glossy and thickened flip the patties in
the sauce until fully coated then finish
with a strip of nori
this might be my fair one yet perfect
texture super buttery smooth this is a
win-win for me